pues hasta ahorita que lo que vamos
bastante bien y ya hemos visto varias
cosas acerca de las matrices las
matrices siempre se denotan con letras
mayúsculas así que vamos a tomar en este
vídeo una matriz que sea de 3 x 2 no voy
a tomar la matriz 1 - 2 3 075 y si te
das cuenta esta es una matriz cuya
dimensión es 3 x 2 porque tenemos 3
filas o tres renglones y dos columnas en
este vídeo lo que me voy a preguntar es
cómo definimos la transpuesta de una
matriz esta de aquí va a ser la
transporta mi matriz transpuesta de mi
matriz que acabo de definir la matriz
transpuesta de a y bueno qué quiere
decir esto realmente es una cosa muy
sencilla lo que vamos a hacer para
transponer una matriz es que cada una de
sus filas o cada uno de sus renglones lo
vamos a convertir en columnas y después
cada una de sus columnas suena muy
lógico lo vamos a convertir en una fila
o en un renglón es justo lo que hay que
hacer para encontrar la transpuesta de
una matriz
así que veamos tenemos que pasar todas
las filas a columnas o dicho de otra
manera lo que es lo mismo pasar todas
las columnas a filas
decíamos que tenía una dimensión de tres
por dos porque tenemos una dos tres
filas por una dos columnas tres filas
por dos columnas y por lo tanto a tener
una dimensión de tres por dos ahora qué
va a pasar cuando yo me fijé en la
transporta pues lo primero que sabemos
es que como las filas se van a volver
columnas y las columnas se van a volver
filas
entonces la dimensión de atrás puesta va
a ser de dos por tres dos por tres muy
bien y quién va a ser a atrás pues está
bueno pues para esto lo que vamos a
hacer es recordar la definición de
transpuesta de a que acabamos de ver
todas las mis filas se convierten en
columnas por lo tanto vamos a agarrar la
primera fila que tenemos aquí
1 - 2 esta fila la voy a pasar a
transpuesta como columna 1 - 2 ahora me
voy a fijar en la segunda fila que tenía
en amd 30 y ahora lo voy a poner como
columna 3
ahora voy a fijar en la tercera fila que
tenían a este de aquí 75 y la voy a
poner aquí como columna o dicho de otra
manera las columnas pasan a hacer filas
vamos a ver si no nos equivocamos mi
primera columna era la columna 1 37 y
aquí la tenemos como fila 1 37 perfecto
vamos bien ahora vamos a fijarnos en la
segunda columna menos 205 y aquí la
tenemos como fila perfecto y como mi
segunda fila menos 205 muy bien por lo
tanto ya encontramos la transpuesta de
esta matriz am a ver vamos a ver otro
ejemplo creo que hasta ahorita le vamos
entendiendo bastante bien voy a decir
que ve es una matriz de dos por dos la
matriz menos 15
y 3 esta es una matriz de 2 por 2 y
adivinen que su transpuesta también va a
ser de 2 por 2 porque las columnas van a
pasar a ser filas y las filas columnas
pero como tenemos dos filas
van a ser dos columnas y dos columnas
van a ser dos filas por lo tanto en este
caso que tenemos una matriz cuadrada es
decir que tienen las mismas cantidades
de filas
de columnas va a terminar también siendo
una matriz cuadrada entonces vamos a
hacer lo menos 15 y después tengo pi y 3
esta primera fila la convertía en
columna y ahora esta segunda fila la voy
a convertir también en columna filas a
columnas
y 3 aquí tenemos mi segunda columna que
en la matriz original era una fila